so careful now in a workshop south of
Frankfurt Christian Heinz is doing what
he loves best he's fixing a car he shall
be shut his eyes I've been fiddling with
cars since I was about seven or eight so
this under fun has he learned it from my
dad he was an auto body specialist too
and he passed it on to me the 20 year
old has already won every competition in
Germany now he's got three days to
trained intensively for the world skills
Championships demasiadas new home
comment in Asia the people are taken off
the job they get time to prepare for the
skills championships and generally have
a trainer with them all day and they
work that way often for an entire year
that means they've trained for the
competition in a way far different from
the way we do Elena singers only been
given a week after train at 21 she's
Germany's printing champion say I might
have y'all done I finished my training
in May I was in the semi-finals in
October which i won that was great and
in July it's on to Leipzig colors are
key in printing she checks with her
advisor to see if the poster looks as it
should technical skill is decisive for
printers and good eyes all the
instruments in the world can't make up
for those
Plus not be flowy mono what always has
been and still is important is the
ability to see color with Thailand
Coonan a printer has to see and evaluate
color by Allah despite all the technical
support from automatic measuring
instruments these are basic skills you
know the job is hectic so you've got to
be able to understand things quickly and
set up the press quickly back at the
body shop Christian Heinz is under time
pressure a BMW needs a replacement part
it's the same task he'll face at the
world skills in July then my next patent
device when the experts are there I have
to remove the side panel of Easton
paycheck how I apply the adhesive
whether I've hit all the spots then I
have to position it clamp it fasten it
with screws when I'm done I need you the
clock is ticking is the adhesive
everywhere it's supposed to be and will
it fit me kya kya checks all the work
six years ago he took part in the world
skills himself in Tokyo now he's
training his successor Christian Hines
their big chance is that the latest
technology using adhesives and rivets
rather than welding is part of the task
does heist our toughest competitors from
Asia didn't know about that in time they
didn't know what kind of vehicle it
would be what brand so many of them have
practiced welding and other techniques
which we won't even be faced with this
time cockpit in bed come so Germany has
a bit of a home advantage at the master
printer Elena singer has been in hiding
back all week but she hasn't seen many
tourist sites practice has priority her
life is dominated by presses and
technology this is an aluminium plate
it's an image carrier you can see it
well here these blue areas are
lipophilic
they absorb the colored ink and the
light spots are hydrophilic and after
inks and water have been applied the
lipophilic come out colored and that
happens with all four colors at the same
time she only has a few days to practice
on Heidelberg's latest models then young
printers from 13 countries will compete
against each other it is the competition
for printers give out in vizag talk it's
me I goodies this is the only
competition I know of especially in
printing it's the only opportunity to
compare yourself with other countries
folks and hairdressers have several
contests plus you can only compete once
so you've got one chance and you don't
know where you stand going in kind of
[ __ ] my [ __ ] stayed all that's left to
do now is relax exhale and hope that the
colors turn out right at the world
skills competition and Leipzig at the
beginning of July